bonjour en poil alors de quoi va-t-il s
alliera l'otan précisément oui bien le
chef de la diplomatie ukrainienne se
rend aujourd'hui à bruxelles afin de
rencontrer le secrétaire général de
l'alliance atlantique jens stoltenberg
dont le contexte que l'on connaît dans
ce contexte de hausse des tensions
depuis maintenant plusieurs semaines
le time code le timing de cette
rencontre est aussi important la semaine
dernière le président ukrainien avait
appelé l'otan à accélérer l'adhésion de
son pays avec l'objectif d'envoyer un
vrai signal un signal fort à la russie
diplomatie ukrainienne qui s'activent on
appris que volodymyr zielinski pourrait
également se rendre en france dans la
semaine
pour rappel les deux camps se rejettent
la responsabilité de cette hausse des
tensions kiev dénonce les mouvements de
troupes russes à la frontière avec les
républiques autoproclamées de donner à
ce qu'est de lougansk tandis que moscou
dénonce des provocations et craignait
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
explications antoine clé